imagine you're the owner of a small
software development firm and you want
to scale your business up
however a small team size the
unpredictability of demand and limited
resources are roadblocks for this
expansion
that's when you hear about cloud
computing but before investing money
into it you decide to draw up the
differences between on-premise and
cloud-based computing to make a better
decision
when it comes to scalability you pay
more for an on-premise setup and get
lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them on the other hand cloud
computing solutions are offered by cloud
service providers who manage and
maintain the servers saving you both
money and space
then we have data security on-premise
systems offer less data security
thanks to a complicated combination of
physical and traditional i.t security
measures whereas cloud computing systems
offer much better security and lets you
avoid having to constantly monitor and
manage security protocols in the event
that a data loss does occur the chance
for data recovery with on-premise setups
are very small
in contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance
on-premises systems also require
additional teams for hardware and
software maintenance loading up the
costs by a considerable degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially
so now thinking that cloud computing is
a better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand computing services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis
in simpler words rather than managing
files and services on a local storage
device you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from
one you have buses which represent
public clouds in this case the cloud
infrastructure is available to the
public over the internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers
two then you have the option of using
your own car
this represents the private cloud with
the private cloud the cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization this can be
managed by the organization or a third
party and finally you have the option to
hail a cab
this represents the hybrid cloud
a hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models there are three major service
models available es pass and sas
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle-free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators
if your organization requires resources
like storage or virtual machines is is
the model for you you only have to
manage the data runtime middleware
applications and the os while the rest
is handled by the cloud providers
next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications
this service model enables users to
deploy applications without the need to
acquire manage and maintain the related
architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers
and finally we have sas
sas or software as a service involves
cloud services for hosting and managing
your software applications
software and hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution
if you'd rather not worry about the
hassles of owning any it equipment the
sas model would be the one to go with
with sas the cloud service provider
handles all components of the solution
required by the organization
time for a quiz now in which of the
following deployment models are you as
the business responsible for the
application data and operating system
one is
two
pass
three
sas
four is and pass
let us know your answer in the comments
section below for a chance to win an
amazon voucher
coming back to cloud computing some of
the most popular cloud computing
services in the market are aws or amazon
web services microsoft azure and google
cloud platform
want to learn more about them and how
they differ from each other
click on the top right corner for an
analysis of how these service platforms
are different from each other
and on that note we have come to the end
of this video we hope you found this
informative and helpful if you enjoyed
this video a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
don't forget to subscribe to the simply
learn channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update on the latest
trending technologies
you